دوله لا تتجاوز مساحتها نصف كيلو متر مربع
لكنها قبله روحيه لاكثر من مليار شخص في
العالم
لها جواز سفر خاص بها وطوابع بريد ولوحات
سيارات وعلم ونشيد وطني وجريده رسميه تصدر
يوميا وبرامج التلفزيونيه واخرى اذاعيه
باربعين لغه مختلفه
هنا الفاتيكان حيث الدوله الاصغر مساحه
والاقل سكانا في العالم
تقع الفاتيكان في وسط العاصمه الايطاليه
روما على الضفه الغربيه لنهر التيبر
الشهير منحت الاستقلال في السابع من يونيو
حزيران عام
1929 على اثر توقيع معاهده لاتران في عهد
الزعيم بنيتو موسوليني وفيكتور ايمانويل
ملك ايطاليا والبابا بيوس الحادي عشر تبلغ
مساحه الفاتيكان الاجماليه 44 هكتارا اي
حوالي 0.44 كيلو مترا مربعا وهي محاطه
باسوار تعود الى القرون الوسطى وعهد
النهضه وتتالف من سته مداخل رئيسيه ثلاثه
منها فقط مفتوحه للزوار
تحيط بالدوله الصغيره الكثير من المباني
المهيبه بينها كتدرائيه القديس بطرس التي
شيدت في القرن الرابع الميلادي واعيد
بناؤها خلال القرن السادس عشر وهي المبنى
الاكثر روعه في المدينه وثاني اكبر مبنى
ديني بعد كنيسه ياموسوكرو في العالم
المسيحي يضم الفاتيكان نفقا يربطه بقلعه
سانت انجيلو على ضفاف نهر التيبر وقد شيد
في عام
1277 بهدف تامين الهروب للباباوات في حاله
الخطر تمتد امتيازات الفاتيكان الى خارج
الحدود الاقليميه للمدينه لتشمل اكثر من
عشره مبان اخرى في روما اضافه الى قلعه
جاندولفو المقر الصيفي للبابا في منطقه
البان هيلز
في داخل الدوله متاحف ومعارض ومجموعات
فنيه لا تقدر بثمن ومكتبه تضم مليون و600
الف كتاب مطبوع ومئه وخمسين الف مخطوطه
قديمه يعود كثير منها الى عصور ما قبل
المسيحيه
الحبر الاعظم او البابا هو راس الكنيسه
الكاثوليكيه في الدوله ويمثل ارثا روحيا
وثقافيا عمره اكثر من الفي عام ويتبعه نحو
مليار وثلاثمائه الف كاثوليكيا في العالم
اكثر من اربعين في المئه منهم يعيشون في
امريكا اللاتينيه ويعاون الباب في اداره
شؤون الفاتيكان لجان يفوض اليها صلاحياته
في حين يعهد بالسلطه التشريعيه الى لجنه
برئاسه كاردينال والسلطه التنفيذيه الى
لجنه اخرى يعاونها امين عام
اللغه الرسميه في الفاتيكان هي اللاتينيه
الا ان اللغه الايطاليه هي اللغه الرئيسيه
التي تستخدم على نطاق واسع بين العاملين
يبلغ عدد السكان الاجمالي قرابه 800 شخص
فقط معظمهم من الكهنه والراهبات الى جانب
عشرات الموظفين الذين يعملون في وظائف
سكرتاريه ووظائف تجاريه وخدميه
ماذا عن اقتصادها تستورد الدوله جميع
الامدادات تقريبا بما في ذلك الطعام
والمياه والكهرباء والغاز لا توجد ضريبه
دخل ولا قيود على الاموال تستمد دخلها من
المساهمات الطوعيه لاكثر من مليار من
الروم الكاثولي في جميع انحاء العالم
اضافه الى ما تحصل عليه من عوائد
الاستثمارات وبيع الطوابع والعملات
المعدنيه والمطبوعات
[موسيقى]